this is our real thoughts on cats and
dogs the cinematic classic yes uh uh but
with the go blue man I they really like
to have a landmark uh um ah going with
that Independence Day to then uh and
these surgeons change the sequel change
the world the whole video here is just
gonna be done in Jeff Goldblum the whole
time
uh uh cats and dogs yes thoughts
enquiries it says my favorite line when
we were watching this is when he sees
the talking cat for the first time he
just like oh it's that kind of movie oh
that's the kind of movie I did you know
I'll tell you something right now when I
saw the trailer for this I'll be honest
because everybody's like oh it looks so
stupid I said that it looked funny to me
I thought this was a funny idea I
thought it could be very humorous um and
even some of those setups are not that
bad but it's like this just seems
horribly misdirected and when I you know
you remember like when we saw like baby
bettas fetch a big pig in the city and
how dark and weird it was but also like
strangely dramatic and stuff and that's
what happens when you have the director
of Mad Max - yeah
and when those animals talked and when
they gave a look in a stare you felt
like Mitt they're really talking to each
other they're really really good you
know you know they can't understand what
they're doing but they just kept the
focus and they were there and this the
whole time you could just see like them
waving the bone and then looking around
and then they just move the mouth I mean
that's just so distracting especially in
a comedy I'm leaving the problem here is
that the idea was sound you started
thinking that you know maybe if I you
could it's not to bug me but the
execution was unharmonious um it's one
of those things where it's like a
cordoned if you're well okay shut up
God dissonant you can do a Goldblum
impression you started yes but you have
good good
though you oh I started Jonah stop oh oh
no no no I see what's going on here this
jealousy
this is giant jealous of your goal bloom
huh it doesn't matter I know that the
person does the best goldwyn is
egoraptor who taught us know we were
like his minions I never saw his I have
any time where the Khan and they're like
you do a great go boom impression I'm
like thank egoraptor yeah no he taught
me the pattern which is just aah aah pop
aah pop aah aah aah um I always
interrupt sentences with little
interjections and ahhs aah aah
um so this movie like cuz well we did
this like it got a lot of hits pretty
fast and I was like just feel like Miami
feelin this hand like a follow anybody
who was a kid at that age when this one
kid was so 10 years something like that
anybody who was a kid at that age
between ages of like 5 to 13 knobblies
probably saw this movie um I also feel
like when it was released
I seem to ever memory it was the only
family film out at the times as well as
it had the lucky break up like that was
like Pixar nothing else yeah yeah I was
like wow those one of those seasons
where there was no other major family
film um you know when you see the
trailer for this it's like the biggest
war going on is right under your nose
and you just see that cute little cat
with this Russian accent coming out you
know I I think about the baby puppy and
stuff it's like it's it looks funny then
a cute little uh you know cat with the
white hair and everything saying we're
trying I can't come in a world it's like
let's go work this could actually be fun
Callaghan I can't you think it's a great
idea yeah um um even the funny thing is
even the CGI which I would have animated
it classically yeah they're like really
Willie's a better movie that tapped into
this was fucking bolt yeah I loved that
movie I would have done it more like
that where it's like a CGI movie but
even a CGI animated the whole way
through not seven real yeah with live
footage but it even then I didn't even
mind that as much as I thought I would
it just I didn't like any of the
characters except for the bloom
and I liked the UH who's playing the kid
down to Louise oh the main bad can yeah
oh oh no not time to always it's like
what's he dead or no i yeah maybe I want
to see you from kissing a hole but I
don't know don't quote me on that uh
it's it's some sort or it's like you
seem it's like I'm four mice apart all
you want I don't know every actor is
cats and fucking door um but I liked it
I liked him I liked the Russian cat I
liked the ninja cat but the main
character the fucking dog yeah the Tobey
Maguire the ally Coughlin just immediate
kill a movie have them as your stars
Alec Baldwin Tobey Maguire dogs yeah um
yeah I just was so uninvested and I'm
like have you made it just about the
secret agent dogs Mad Dog who went more
adventure in in and he gets warmed up in
this five and I'm sorry Uncle Ben and
spiders dogged like it if you had made
it like a real secret agent dog who was
in on this I'm getting I think it would
have been way better making him this
like schmuck dog that gets pulled into
this by mistake and he's just so
ineffectual well you know it's gonna be
lazy with a dust mop I wouldn't have
noticed
I remember this movie got like mixed
reviews when it came out it wasn't like
positive wasn't negative somewhere in
the middle and it was like yeah okay
well I I don't think it might be good
maybe people just aren't open to this
idea and stuff so when it came out to
video I rented a I'm watching and I'm
like okay a little awkward but I'm still
you know some of the shots were fine
with the cats like an evil and stuff
like that and as soon as a cut yet to
the Tobey Maguire talk say haven't you
guys ever dreamed about anything have
you ever wanted it's more about like
shit this is gonna suck oh you know what
kills me what fucking kills me I said
this from the beginning he's going on
this fucking rant about like I want more
is like a Disney burger I once more he
goes on this rant
he lives on a fucking far yeah no I get
it if you're a human it is like I want
much more than this viventia alive but
if your dog this is fucking hell
yeah things are better live on a farm
you got all the space to run to explore
to bark at random animals you know and I
want to hear this via yeah I want to go
to suburbia where I can just live in a
house and the backyard is my playground
I guess what fuckin dog wants that I
could connect with a boy a really bad
acting boy but that poor kid I was so
bad ripping into kid activist cuz
they're kids you know but it's like it
was not yeah yeah I haven't seen little
kid acting that good in a gun movie
since Binger high it's just one of those
things I think this was at a time where
it's like Pixar I think was just
starting to come out it was like hey
maybe kids films can be smart and
intelligent but it's like Pixar was it
all the other ones were that crap yeah
so the very base from what your starting
is bullshit yeah cuz that dog would have
wanted to stay in the farm and then the
second major problem is it's cats dogs
versus each other and of course the film
is like dogs great all cats evil because
their brains it's really what's going on
there Wow very anti dog I'm not anti dog
I'm just anti it's always like Oh dogs
dogs dogs
I just been cancer the smarter creatures
like what they're lazy shiftless
do-nothing and people just pamper them
all damn I guess that's why they're busy
smarter fucking animal that's why
they're trying to take over the world
see they have the intelligence so but so
the whole movies basically based on this
idea that like oh well dogs are better
than cats is that but the cats are the
only interesting characters in the movie
today completely undercuts them more oh
and I don't give a shit about any of the
dogs one of my thing is that you know
with the with the dogs in this movie you
know like like you say you want to make
a connection with them you know but
they're just so not interesting you know
even how cute they make them instead of
a little dog Jos it doesn't work but
like the slapstick in this movie like
whenever there's so much of this word
like we love slats and we left left it
done right and I you sweet they just
have mercy to cart them that's never
seen was a dog gets hit made the catch
up the dog in the van or what I
I wish that was the best scene in the
movie I laughed my ass off ha buddy here
goes outside oh yeah
hey even the sounds that they have going
is like Blue Mountain Dew and that's
like that's not how good slap sticks
work you have to be very selective on
the sound effects you use and they just
threw in random ones how I need that use
that like five times it's very clear the
director was making a cartoon and had no
idea how to make a cartoon yeah I mean
that's even should've handed it to an
animation yeah and and done it and and
it's so funny that this guy would have
to do some of the masks which we all
know oh oh now I don't feel bad for me
yeah well sudden amass makes this movie
look like the fucking guy yeah I will
say this there's gotta
I'm thinking I'm a director on this
movie and it's like hey you can't CGI it
you gotta use animals and pop pins and
some CGI and stuff it's like that is
gotta be tough that's got to be tough to
get these animals to like look when you
want to look have expressions and
emotions and so on so forth I do
slapstick and things like that but then
like like I said you see a baby and you
see baby pig in the city and how well
they do it there and it's like wife
wouldn't they do that maybe they don't
have the budget or the time or something
but you can do clever editing you can
choose better sound effects you can
write a better story
you guys directed so the masks I think
we answered her own question Ari you
know gotta get I'm gonna get back to
this thing though we were talking about
how we're completely disinteresting the
dogs and I'm not an anti dog person
I usually like dogs cats a little better
but I love dog the thing how can you not
he'll automatic sympathy for a dog how
does it movie accomplish that yeah you
should roll over the dog characters
uncomplete like that's it that's just a
gimme that's that's is Archer with its
baby frolics with handed dog characters
to make sympathetic and you can't do it
oh and there's something to when you
hear a certain lie like I said every I
always want to say everything that's
wrong with the movie you can just sum up
in that one scene where you first see
the Tobey Maguire dog because I eat all
the puppies going oh not again
and it's like free people probably
watching today like oh it was that a
thing back then no it was already dated
even bag man just thank God he didn't
sing I want to be we're the people of
he'll sing the song for spider-man 3
play to it which was already half CG
anyway we what up Toby regards I don't
hate Toby McGuire at all but when he
ends up in a bad film or a it makes it
easier to hate yeah more or a scene or
something that does him no favors it's
way easier he's very easy to hate yeah
there's some errors have a charisma that
if you put them in scenes like that
you're still like ah but you know it's
like oh it's still Christopher Walken ah
it's I even like Jeff Goldblum like is
but Toby McGuire not so much I just
kinda want punch him in the face
yeah it's every time another gets gonna
be required sure he's a nice guy but
like if I see him on the screen you know
I have a 50/50 chance if he was saying
hey I like you in the first two
spider-man movies or punching him in the
face and saying that's for cats enough
yeah yeah there's something to that guy
where I always feel like you know I'm
sure he's a cool guy and it always looks
like he's trying his hardest like he's
really doing his damn this you know it
can't be easy being spider-man you know
and all these other role like selling
Seabiscuit
uh but yeah but there is there is Jimmy
has a to the voice in the dirt is he he
has resting derp face that does not help
him now not as bad as Ted Cruz resting
bitchface
but he can be great in comedies um I'm
trying to think of a comedy where he was
great but I know I see that I know he
has been legitimately funny and stuff um
but you know when the yesterday's
enjoyed anything how many on the tip of
my tongue I'm thinking I was like no he
was funny and I can't remember what film
it was but yeah helping RK I guess not
but when he wants to join dude why
anymore fine but these does not work in
this film whatsoever horribly miscast um
so what the hell else can you say about
this movie it's just one of those films
where it's like it's one of those where
it's almost like I wish we almost like
could rewrite it or redo it it's done
because you get
get working you know you can see this
being funny but you know it's one of
those words that needs to be kids well
I'm sure they just gave it to some once
again just turn it out whatever it so be
home hit Adil to pics our Brad Bird or
you know the the team's behind like
something like Samurai Jack or Hotel
Transit I know like so people who knows
slapstick yeah um but yeah it's just oh
I remember what I say that the last big
thing I'll say about this is that there
was a time I remember I came here if I
brought this up in the quote-unquote
Dark Age of movies or whatever editorial
but there was a time when it's like
movie directing right now it's about how
do you serve the story how do you serve
the franchise how do you serve the
characters kind of what movies just
going to be and stuff uh but there was a
good like you know seven or eight years
where everything was how can the
director get their vision out and they
want to look really weird and everything
was really wide angle or fish eye lens
and there's all these really weird
angles and every director wanted to be
noticed
Burton wachowski fan yeah every director
wanted their style they wanted their
unique stamp and it really got in the
way and it really kind of destroyed what
should have been good movies Mystery Men
is another one you remember that one
where it's like this is actually kind of
a funny idea it could be good but the
directing I totally killed it okay there
are some things in Mystery Men I thought
from a directing perspective and
cinematography is a little overwrought
but hey you're way too hard on that
movie I don't think honestly I like
Mystery Men and I didn't think the
directing was ed there's a few standout
scenes I'm like why why they do a
fishing lens why is it point of view
camp lake but I think overall I actually
worked out you know that would have been
so much funnier if it was done kind of
more of a matter-of-fact style what
everything just looks very common by
instead they want a city to look weird
and the old folks home at the beginning
really odd and weird and everybody's
going like this and that's not how that
comedy is supposed to work it
I'm really thinking I don't have a world
and I disagree I think I think I liked
it in its own little universe I I
enjoyed it for that
all right well didn't maybe I that that
maybe you're wrong I'm right or more
likely uh I am right because I do the uh
uh uh uh uh better go blue
well can we all agree that Mystery Men
would have been a lot better if Goldman
was in it ah well absolutely yeah go
boom slap diamond I would have been
called The Wizard of Oz that was like
when we were watching this movie like we
just couldn't shut up with our go Bob
say we just kept going I will say this
he he is the funniest thing kind of in
the movie because he's he's a movie be I
love films where there's like two
separate competing films and you get the
impression that there was some other
movie filming in the basement that you
can't see but that interrupts this movie
occasionally like that's what's going on
this Jeff Goldblum was in some sort of
weird like spoof of the fly going on in
his basement party help me like you know
with this freaking allergy thing he was
trying to come up with it I'm just you
know I'm more interest in the movie
they're shooting downstairs the one
who's shooting upstairs
uh you know I really love how there's
that sounds so strange because we may
find them so much but there's like
kindness resurgence of Goldblum and like
it's like he came in and everybody loved
him they kept doing the same stick and
everybody hated him and now it's like he
knows my schtick and he's having fun
with it
lost I had for me I lost where I didn't
like go blossom or was the one where I'm
like if he doesn't shut the fuck yeah I
did powder and it to me he annoys the
hell out of me an independent a well
we'll see hop resurgence do see here's
the problem with lost world in
particular independent says goofy mouth
fat see here's the difference between
Independence Day and lost world
Independence Day instinct instinctively
I feel like roland emmerich has lost the
style instinctively knew somehow it was
garbage yeah that's a diary and I think
I think Goldblum instinctively knew it
was garbage
and it plays off like that he plays what
is exactly I mean exactly the same
character in lost world
hmm I mean there's that oh my God look
at all the hell ganas are not it's same
shit but lost world is so fucking
pretentious and full of itself and
thinks it's saying something important
from a book that Crichton just wrote for
a fucking paycheck and you read that
thing it's go you're just like seriously
like this is it like somebody just wrote
you a check is like all right here's
your sequel Michael hate hate the book
hate the movie and it completely comes
off terrible in that because it's
supposed to kind of be taken seriously I
mean he's trying the Goldblum it up and
stick it up but it's set everything as I
as a message just trying to be really
serious you're like no no we have some
oh and they're saying if it's gone by
the way is that yeah everything he says
God day they say he did send a secret
weapon was that me it's like yeah total
get off every so that's where I would go
booms that no no no John you're making
all a mistake
yes got yet you know a movie with
Goldblum in Vince Vaughn's supposed to
be taken seriously I mean there's a
problem right there
I do I do love Vince Vaughn but I only
income yeah he's one of my favorite
comedic actors whenever he said like the
fuck could be Sal I like I but that's a
big Michelle I laughed my ass off I'm
like maybe he was trying to play that's
yeah if you would I'm gonna stab himself
maybe he's subconsciously trying to make
the dramas comedies too but we really
section what I was getting to is that
Goldblum is surprisingly kind of funny
here because again it's kind of his
shtick and he kind of knows it you know
we just saw him on a Kimmy Schmidt
hilarious
a lot of masculine roles I've seen in a
one of those apartment downtown
commercial hilarious and I feel like
he's aware of it now and he's having fun
that really what I feel like needs to do
and honestly too is Christopher walkin
yeah walk on the same thing I think
early I'm walking was serious and now
he's is like oh I get it
you all think I'm funny well just be
funny I think there's and even though I
think the movies gonna be
shit the second Independence Day I think
it's probably a really good choice for
him cuz like you know he's gonna yuck
that out haha checkmate
oh that like hit the Landmarks huh hey
you know I mean better pieces up uh
everything's employees and yeah what
happens
checkmate you're selling you're saying a
lot of solid Oh
but plastic lunch box that's uh you're
right because that's what they do with
the movie store about all the evils are
tried to sell this idea what they sell
you know Will Smith I'm kind of out to
like I'm in Italy for Goldblum but the
lack of Will Smith like I'm like because
he was the only hey it was only fun
thing a memo yeah it was Will Smith and
Jeff Goldwyn we're like it like all that
other filler plot going on I'm I don't
care about any of these people I like
Bill I like Bill Pullman like Bill
Pullman is amazing but Bill Pullman is
my president it was only at the very end
way to start giving speeches and going
up in the plane that I'm like okay now
this is really funny but otherwise all
he did was just kind of stare off into
the distance yeah I think maybe these in
you guys even can't afford galaxy keep
it even cats and dogs cats Oh that'd be
interesting going yeah that's what they
eat he's a cranky old man who just was
woken up ah that felt a little bit
princess except for that he was grated
um so yeah clear we're talking about
things here so anything else you can
think to talk about this Vicky I the
only thing that struck me odd is just
not bono I just I prefer to have my
movies even as ridiculous as they are be
grounded in some sense of reality and
the reaction off the kid with dogs and
cats suddenly talking in front of him
blindfolded and tied to a charity is
like and the moms all like word troubles
like now or vive I got this like you so
nonchalant about it all I'm like really
because that would be a whole bunch for
me to deal with it one day
cats are trying to take over the world
you're gonna be burned in a factory fire
you know what
is live on the ion refine would be funny
if the mother was trying to call my dad
he's panicking then she panics making it
worse but no it's just you know she's
supposed to panic you know which I mean
that seemed to her credit was actually a
little fight like she was a little funny
but yeah with him as I I'm not afraid
and I'm just like what I cannot your
razor misiones right now yeah you know
it is I just I feel like it's a very
unrealistic trait for any kid to have
even in a bullshit movie yeah even
though the bullshit movie just struck me
as unrealistic and it struck me as one
of those moves like well we can't really
scare the kids like fuck you you can
scare the kids I grew up in the age now
it's like to be scared now this is just
get us inside of the mask you can scare
here you could throw a little danger I
feel like the movie was too much trying
to wink like they're all gonna be okay
oh my god that doesn't make it into like
if I were a kid I'd be like one
everything's gonna be fine like I just I
don't know well and you as as a kid you
wanna be invested in it as well the main
character is until a be the main
character doesn't give a shit yeah I
mean the character that supposed to
represent you as a kid is not scared why
should you be invested you know if he's
not Wester why should you be invested
that kid should follow natural kid
things like maybe flying in a UFO would
be wow this is legitimately awesome
there are some things but that scenario
I'm like oh shit we're in fucking
trouble my reactor this is like now
we're good we got this someone but even
though your time to fly the Navigator
even that had like the fear of him going
in and not knowing what this is what it
winds up actually funny thing well that
is a good example I was actually
thinking of explorers but not mama to
buy a the spaceship that'll drink but so
yeah I don't know it just struck me as I
just struck me is how tone-deaf the
movie kind of is just overall like it it
doesn't know really what's it trying to
appeal the little kids but it's not
really good cartoon it it's trying to
make dogs be better but the cats are the
only characters worth watching is it dad
yeah no it's um pretty bad so uh that's
all we can say about that and what else
can you say but dogs and cats living
together mass hysteria uh uh uh it's
true this man has no